[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 99
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel,
who is breaking the mics.
Hi, Mark.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: Apparently,
being extra klutzy today.
I am well.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm very, very good.
I'm very excited to
have David East back.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
He popped in a little while
ago for a little segment,
but now we actually have
him for an entire episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And we're going to be talking
about Cloud Functions,
and specifically Cloud
Functions for Firebase
and Firebase Hosting,
which basically allows you
to do all of the serverless.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Serverless.
MARK MANDEL: After that,
we're going to sit down,
and I'm going to
ask the question--
I like Google Cloud,
but I would like
to learn maybe something
like with an online class.
Can I do that?
That would be cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Like, basically, I love
trainings and stuff like that.
It is better than just
reading documentations.
So we checked, and there's
some really cool things
that actually also are new.
So definitely checking
it out, but that
will be at the end
of the episode.
Before that, we have our
cool things of the week.
The first one, it is
something quite cool.
It is related to Cloud IAM, so
Identity and Access Management.
And it is the fact that now
you can define your own custom
roles.
Until now, we have
had roles like--
a long time ago, we had
like project owner, editor,
and viewer.
And that was pretty much it.
And then we started
having things
like now you can be
an App Engine editor,
or for specific things.
You can write into cloud
storage, or stuff like that,
but not read.
That doesn't make much sense.
But you can read, but not
write, stuff like that.
Now, what you can do
is you can actually
create new roles that
have specific permissions
and then apply
those to your users.
So you can create
new ones, which
is really powerful because,
in your organization,
you might have someone that
should be able to do something
really specific, and you want to
allow them to do that and just
that.
MARK MANDEL: It's nice.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's just things
that people need,
so it's good that it's there.
MARK MANDEL: I really like this
for ongoing maintenance, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: As new
products come out
or maybe you realize
you missed a permission
across a large swath of users,
if you assign them that role,
then you can just
change that role.
And that gives you a
lot of flexibility, too,
going forward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Did you
say a swath of users?
MARK MANDEL: A swath.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
such a cool word.
Very good.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
second cool thing
of the week-- it's
something that
is really, really
cool-- it is mixing
the two hot things of the year.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's mixing Cloud ML,
so machine learning,
with serverless.
So the title of the these
"Medium" blog posts,
it's "Serverless Transferred
Learning with Cloud ML Engine
and Keras."
And it is really interesting
from at least the point
of view of transfer learning.
Transfer learning, if you
don't know what it is--
MARK MANDEL: No idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically, it is
you're able to
learn things better
once you know other things.
That's a whole point.
Like, if you know
how to play tennis,
learning how to play table
tennis, it's easier, right?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that's
basically the whole idea
applied to neural networks.
So the idea here is that
they use Inception, I think.
Yeah, they use
Inception, which is
a neural network
that has been trained
to recognize a lot of things.
Like, that's basically
what we use internally
for Google Photos.
Not the same, but we use
something quite similar.
What you can do is draw the
last part of the neural network
and then retrain it
to learn something
slightly different-- like to
train, is this an elephant?
Or things like that,
specific things
that are not necessarily what
the neural network was designed
to.
So you can adapt it
to your use case.
So he talks about how
to do this in Keras.
Keras is just another
machine learning library.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's Keras.
It's a different one.
And the cool thing is that,
then, what they do is--
OK, so now that we've
designed this neural network,
how do we train it?
And rather than training
it locally, what they do
is that use Cloud ML Engine.
And Cloud ML Engine, that's the
serverless part of the thing,
right?
You just send it there,
and it's trained.
You don't need to care about
how many machines are running
or anything, it just happens.
And not only that,
but then, afterwards,
once you have the model,
you can just click a button
and start serving it.
So then you also have
serverless predictions.
So it is all serverless
and all machine learning,
and it's an awesome blog post.
So go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: And it's also
written by a community member.
So I'm going to massacre
this person's name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's see.
MARK MANDEL: Hayato Yoshikawa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'd say
that is a pretty good effort.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So it's pretty good.
And speaking of
community articles,
I've got a second
one here from--
this is probably easier--
Mark Betz, SRE at Olark.
He has an article written
called "Five Things
Learned using Terraform
to Manage Google Cloud
Infrastructure," or even
just "Cloud Infrastructure,"
actually.
So if you're not
familiar with Terraform,
it's an automation solution
for managing infrastructure
in the cloud.
I love automation.
I keep going on about deployment
manager, things like that.
He's basically written down five
different things that he thinks
are good best practices
for using Terraform
with Google Cloud
and some practices
that you can take
advantage of there.
It's worth having read to see
if it's going to apply to you.
I always advocate that
people use automation
when setting up their cloud
infrastructure because things
go wrong, and it's always
good when you can tear them
up and tear them down easily.
So yes, go have a read.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
It's a great blog post.
But my favorite part,
do you know what it is?
MARK MANDEL: What's that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's Mark's bio.
He's SRE at Olark, husband,
father of three smart kids,
two unruly dogs,
and a resentful cat.
I want to meet that cat.
MARK MANDEL: I just assume
all cats are resentful.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: I have
biases towards dog.
I'm sorry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Dog person, clearly.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'm a dog person.
Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So I guess it's now time,
after judging dogs and cats,
to go talk with David East about
Cloud Functions for Firebase
and Firebase Hosting.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Today, I am very pleased to
announce yet another developer
advocate at Google
joining us today,
though not from
cloud specifically,
but we'll let him
talk about that.
David East, thank you
so much for joining us.
How are you doing today?
DAVID EAST: Doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We're going to have a
chat about how Cloud
Functions and Firebase Hosting.
But before we do
that, why don't you
tell us a little bit about
what you do at the Googles?
DAVID EAST: So as
you probably know,
the Google is a search company.
Go to the website and type
in what you want to learn.
But it also does other things,
like Cloud-based stuff outside
of Google Cloud.
So I work on Firebase, which
is a mobile app platform
for Android, iOS, and web.
And I primarily work on
the web side of things,
so I work on things like the
real-time database, which
is a way for you to
store and sync data
in real time without having
to run your own server;
Cloud Functions, which is
a way of writing server
code without having
to have a server;
and also Firebase
Hosting, which is really
a first-class web
hosting experience that's
kind of built for performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've had many--
well, many-- a bunch of
episodes on Firebase, I'd say.
We even had once this
guy called David East
that answered questions of the
week back then in episode 15.
DAVID EAST: I
wouldn't trust him.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
the thing that we
want to talk about
today, specifically,
it's two different things.
One is Firebase
Hosting, which you
mentioned real quick right
now, and Cloud Functions
for Firebase.
And I don't really know
anything about any of those.
I know about Firebase, like the
database and authentication,
which is really cool, but
not really Firebase Hosting.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what is it really?
DAVID EAST: Firebase Hosting,
it's really near and dear to me
because I joined
Firebase back in 2014,
before it was at Google.
And my first
project was actually
to help ship Firebase Hosting.
So it's kind of like a
special thing for me.
And when we were coming up with
the idea for Firebase Hosting,
we had a lot of
people at the time
who were using real-time
database and authentication
to build their apps,
but they didn't really
have any place to host them--
so if you're a web app.
And we had a lot of people
reach out and be like, hey,
can you make this
any easier for us?
So rather than just kind
of creating a place where
you can throw up your files,
we kind of thought, all right,
what could we do to make hosting
not just easy for deployment,
but also like really fast?
So what we did was we
came up with this service
where you pretty much install
a command line using NPM.
You do a little initialization.
But then, with just one
command doing Firebase deploy,
we will automatically
just upload those files,
and we will deploy them
out onto our server.
But we actually don't actually
serve from the server,
because we're backed by a CDN.
So you get low latency
all around the globe.
And then you don't have to
worry about things like SSL,
because we automatically hook
up SSL certificate for you.
You don't have to worry
about going out and buying
one or provisioning yourself.
That just sort of happens.
And one of the things we also
do is provide a really easy way
to integrate your own
custom domain into it.
So just kind of like, without
really having to do much,
you can get a full site
deployed, really performant,
really easy.
And you kind of get all
these things out of the box.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So whenever I want to
deploy a website myself,
I never use Firebase Hosting.
So normally, what
I do is either I
use App Engine, which allows
me also to have custom domains,
or I use Google Cloud Storage.
Where is Firebase Hosting?
Is it dynamic, like App Engine?
Is it more like static storage?
DAVID EAST: Well,
that's really what
I'm here to talk about today.
So when we first started
with Firebase Hosting,
we were really only looking
at doing static, so pretty
much all static files.
There's a lot you can do
with a static website.
Everyone kind of reaches
for server code at first,
but you'd be really,
really amazed
at the things you can do with
static generators and stuff
like that.
So for years, we
were only static.
And that's why we were able
to back everything by a CDN
because we didn't have
to worry about running
any code on the server.
But, I guess last March, when
we launched Cloud Functions,
this really opened
up the door for us
to provide an integration with
Firebase Hosting and Cloud
Functions.
And we had been kind
of experimenting
with this for a bit during
our own internal hack weeks.
And the team lead
for Firebase Hosting,
Michael Bleigh, he came up with
this crazy system at the time
where you would basically
create a Cloud Function,
generate some content
with it, and then
you would send that back
to Firebase Hosting, which
would then cache that
content on the CDN
and then back to the user.
And so when the user would
then request the site again,
or another user in
that CDN Edge area,
it wouldn't actually go
back to Cloud Functions
to regenerate it again.
It would just serve
from the CDN Edge.
And we would specify how long
it would live in the Edge.
But it became sort of like the
first time we saw, oh, wow, we
can provide this dynamic content
with this static twist to it.
MARK MANDEL: So you
mentioned something there,
Cloud Functions.
We did do an episode
a little while
ago, Episode 73
with Bret McGowan,
but this is Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
Is that the same thing?
For people who don't
know what it is,
can you explain what it
is and the differences?
It would be really great.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
So Cloud Functions is
basically serverless
compute, server
code, and don't have
to manage your own servers.
And Cloud Functions for
Firebase is this Firebase layer
on top of that.
So it's still Cloud
Functions, the cloud product.
And Cloud Functions for Firebase
is an SDK that we provide you.
So essentially, if you want to
respond to events that happen
in your Firebase ecosystem--
so if something changes
in your database, a user logs
in, you get an event from
Firebase Analytics, or someone
uploads a file from cloud
storage--
you can respond to these events
and then run server code.
And so what we've done
with Cloud Functions
and Firebase Hosting is
we've provided a way to say,
whenever someone hits
this URL for your website,
let's run this code.
And then, when you are
done generating this code,
use a cache control header
and specify how long you want
it to store in the CDN Edge.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So when we put together Cloud
Functions with static hosting,
what sort of things
can you build?
Like, what's possible here?
DAVID EAST: Well, with Cloud
Functions and Firebase Hosting,
there's pretty much not much
you can't do because now you
have the ability to do
dynamic server content
but still present it to
the user as static content.
So before, pretty much whenever
you'd do Firebase deploy,
that was kind of it for you.
You would deploy it out.
All your static files are
going to go out the web.
And if you realize you
had a typo on a page,
or wrote a bug, or
something like that,
you'd have to go out and write
Firebase deploy again and just
redeploy your entire website.
Now, what you can
do is you can still
have a bunch of static pages.
You can break it up to say,
OK, this section of my site
is static, but this
page specifically
or these set of
pages are dynamic.
And at that point, effectively,
whatever a dynamic site can do
is exactly what Cloud Functions
and Firebase Hosting can do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So what I'm thinking
about now is
this would be a really
good idea for someone that
starts with a static
site, and then they
want to add more dynamic
things, like, let's say,
sending email or
something like that.
Is that the use case?
Or do you see also
people building
from scratch on Firebase
plus Cloud Functions?
DAVID EAST: I think
you're totally right.
I think if you start
out with a static site,
and you might be building like
a portfolio page or something
like e-commerce where
you deploy out all
of your static-generated pages--
because if it's static, it's
going to be super, super fast--
but maybe you have a certain
page that is dynamic.
So the register, or the shopping
cart, or something like that
is dynamic, but the profile
pages or the recipe pages,
or something like
that, is all static.
So it's a nice
mix-and-match approach.
But another place that I
see where you kind of just
go dynamic to start with is, if
you're building any JavaScript
framework apps or single-page
applications and stuff like,
that you might want to take
advantage of server-side
rendering those.
And that is pretty easy
because, at that point,
you've created your whole
app that typically would
be client rendered at first.
But with just whatever
frameworks, library code,
you can deploy that
out to the server.
It generates the static HTML and
sends that down to the browser.
I've done the Angular,
Universal, React, Preact, xJS,
Vue.js, all these
server-side rendering apps.
It takes pretty much
like 10 lines of code
or so to get it integrated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So if I understand correctly
then, what you're saying
is that we have all
the static hosting
and that it's
accessible from a CDN.
So it means low latency
and good performance.
And then we have
the Cloud Functions
that are going to generate
the dynamic content
or react to whatever
the user is doing.
And those things
are run somewhere
on Google Cloud Platform, and
then the results are cached?
DAVID EAST: Yes.
So essentially, the cache
is controlled by you
through a cache control header.
Cloud Functions right
now is all in Node.js,
so we use Express to do
the server responses.
So if you're building
an Express.js app,
it's probably about a
handful of lines of code
to just move it over
to Cloud Functions.
But essentially, when you're
ready to send your response
back--
so you get a request
from the user,
you generate your content,
however you do that--
and then right
before you send back,
you just set a cache
control header.
And you essentially will say,
OK, it's a public header.
It has a maxage of this is how
long the browser will cache it,
but then there is
s-maxage which says
this will sit for this
many seconds on the server
or on the CDN.
So in that area, if
one person requests,
it's going to generate it and
do that whole longer round trip.
But then the second time,
the second user, they're
just going to go
straight out to the Edge.
And the Edge is going to have
it, and send it right back,
and avoid running the
Cloud Function again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
then, I imagine, that
is very simple from the code
side of things to control.
For instance, this is something
I never want to cache.
Just simply do not
set those headers,
and that's pretty much it?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
That's really it.
And there's even
more advanced things
you can do with the headers
that are really easy to do.
There's the
stale-while-revalidate header,
which is really cool
for certain use cases.
So if a user makes a request
out to your site and the CDN
notices that, well,
this content is stale,
but what I'm going to
do is I'm going to send
them back the stale version.
And in the background.
I'm going to go
out to your origin
or to your Cloud Function,
generate that content,
and store it back
into the cache.
So the user got
a quick response.
It might be stale
content, but the next user
or the next request will
bring back the fresh content.
And so if you know you
can kind of get away
with serving up
stale content, it's
a really great technique
to give good performance
and also keep that cache warm.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that
is very interesting,
and it brings me to cache
validation, which is a very
cool problem, we all know.
How do you invalidate the cache?
Let's say that you
say, well, this content
is valid for an hour,
and then something
happens that invalidates it.
Is there any way to
tell whatever servers
are caching that
information that they
should ask for the new version?
DAVID EAST: Firebase
Hosting, from the get go,
has really strong cache
and validation strategies--
or I guess really just one
cache validation strategy.
Essentially, with
static hosting,
whenever you say Firebase
deploy, everything
you deploy is in
one atomic version.
If you go to the
Firebase console,
you can actually see
in the Hosting tab
every single version of your
app that you've ever deployed.
And you actually can roll
back to any single one
of those just with one click.
And it's almost instant.
And why we're able to do that
is because, since we have all
these atomic versions,
whenever you deploy out
we're able to contact
each edge and say, hey,
there's a new
version right here.
Just purge everything in
your cache because the user
is going to want
the new version.
And there's nothing
stopping you from doing that
with Cloud Functions
and Firebase Hosting.
So let's say you have like
really aggressive caching
going on in your Cloud
Function, and you
want to cache for half a
day or something like that
because you maybe publish
like two blog posts a day
or something.
And you realize, oh, I want
to publish this sooner,
or there's a typo or
something like that.
When you write Firebase deploy,
it's going to purge the cache.
And even those cache
control headers
are going to be
ignored at that point.
And it's going to know
to go back and fetch
the fresh content.
MARK MANDEL: So
when you deploy, you
said, as a single
unit, that contains
both the static files and your
Cloud Functions for Firebase?
Is it both?
DAVID EAST: Great question.
So you have to kind of
break it up into two pieces
because the Cloud
Functions are deployed out
to their own place, and the
same with Firebase Hosting.
So they're actually in
two separate places,
which is a really nice
way to kind of break up
the two parts of your app.
And you can deploy
them at the same time,
or you can specify
one for the other
and whatever really helps.
Because if you just need
to update your server code,
that's not going to
break your cache.
So if you're just trying
to keep your cache strategy
kind of just humming along,
just deploy your server code.
But if you need to kind of break
the world because everything
needs to be updated, you
have that option, too.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So this sounds hugely powerful.
For a long time, I've
been using probably
App Engine for more of my quote
unquote "serverless" needs.
Does this mean I shouldn't
be using App Engine?
Is there like a
sweet spot for this?
Where should I choose maybe
one thing over another?
DAVID EAST: App Engine has a
lot of really cool add-ons.
And when you're doing things
with longer-lived tasks,
I would definitely
start thinking
about doing your own server.
So any really heavy
compute options,
or just if you're running a
Cron or something like that
on your server,
then App Engine's
definitely the
great place there.
But when you're just
doing very simple things,
like if all you want to do is
build a Handlebars app where
you just have some type of
server templating where you
say, I have some data,
I have a template,
let's generate my HTML, this is
a really great place for that
because it's also just trivial,
like we were talking about
before, to integrate
the caching into it.
So it's this really nice place
for traditional web development
with it.
And also modern,
front-end framework
developing with
server-side rendering
is also a really
good spot for this
because one of the most
expensive parts when you're
doing server side rendering
with JavaScript frameworks
is that regeneration
every single time.
And for most people's websites,
how often do they update?
Unless you're a big,
real-time, live site,
your content might only change
a handful of times a day.
So it doesn't make sense
to just always regenerate.
And this is really where that
caching strategy can help you
because it keeps
that content cached,
and so you don't have to keep
paying that server cost over
and over again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So now I'm thinking,
let's imagine
that I'm trying to build
a to-do app because that's
what everybody builds.
I want to store my
information somewhere.
How would this work?
You would have Firebase
Hosting calling
Cloud Functions for
Firebase and then
that accessing some database?
Or would you recommend directly
using Firebase database?
Where do you store
the information?
How do you decide that?
DAVID EAST: So essentially, you
can store it wherever you want.
You can just stick
it in a JSON file
and upload it with
your Cloud Functions.
Not the best option.
But one of the things we do
that makes it really easy
is we ship the Firebase
admin SDK, which
is this really nice
server SDK for controlling
all these different things
with your Firebase accounts.
And so you get a greater
set of permissions
that you'd expect to do as
the owner of your project.
And what we have is ways
to say, OK, I'm the owner.
I want to go read a
database from this section,
and I want to check out my
authenticated users here.
And so when someone
makes a request,
you're likely going to use
some type of stateful URL.
So whatever route
parameter, you can just
use that to request that data
using the Firebase admin SDK,
get that data back, and then
just template your page,
do whatever's needed.
And so you can use
whatever you want,
but we've made it
really easy to talk
to Firebase database,
or cloud storage,
or something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So then, that means
that you can store the
information wherever you want.
And if you store information
on Firebase database,
then the Cloud
Functions for Firebase
do have access to that
Firebase database.
Is that the case?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
When Cloud Functions
boots up, your credentials
are automatically configured
in that environment.
So it's actually your
Google Cloud credentials.
So whatever that project has
access to, you can tap into.
So if you're using
the Cloud Vision API,
those credentials
are automatically
configured in that environment.
And the same for your
Firebase credentials.
And so it's really
easy to just say, OK,
I'm going to read data from
this section and send it back,
or I need to call
this API, I need
to talk to whatever service
that's in the Google Cloud
or Firebase ecosystem.
All that authentication
and credentialing
is just automatically
taken care of for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So that's almost
burying the lead a little.
I feel like I want
to highlight it.
This seems like a sweet
spot where maybe you
want to cross ecosystems.
Like say you want to do
some stuff in Google Cloud
Platform-- maybe you
have a database there,
or you want to do something
like Cloud Vision--
but also be able
to take advantage
of basically the buttery
sweetness of Firebase.
Would that be kind of accurate?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
Totally.
The fact that you don't have
to worry about your credentials
is really great.
And we also provide
this credentialing
with the Firebase CLI that
you install through NPM.
We have local runners.
So a lot of times, you're
dealing with, oh, I just
want to do this
locally right now.
I don't want to have
to deploy to test this.
Well, we have ways of
testing that locally
with the same credentialing.
But yeah, if you're trying
to talk to Cloud Vision,
you're going to need a server.
And typically, those tend
to not take too long.
And so Cloud Functions and
doing stuff like Cloud Vision
is an amazing sweet spot.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So now I'm curious.
Have you seen any
particular awesome things
that people have built?
Or are there particularly
amazing examples
that you'd like
to highlight here?
DAVID EAST: So I've been doing a
series on server-side rendering
using JavaScript frameworks.
And it was sort of interesting
because I have a lot
of friends who make frameworks.
I've done a 20% project
on the Angular team,
and I talk to a
lot of other people
who are like Ember
team and other teams.
And also, I have a lot of
friends on the Chrome team.
And they have this interesting
approach to doing things
for web performance.
And some of my friends
on the Chrome team
aren't totally convinced that
server-side rendering is going
to be better for you, rather
than just sort of booting up
from scratch because it's a
lot of tax on the main process.
And so, one of the things I went
out to do was is kind of figure
out, OK, what's the truth here?
What is really the
performance story?
And so what I kind
of found out is
that, if you're doing
server-side rendering
wrong, yeah, it's going
to make you think slower.
You're going to see the
page a lot faster, maybe,
because your time to first bite
actually might be well worse.
But what I realized is, when
you bring all these things
in together, you can actually
get an amazing performance
story out of server-side
rendering your JavaScript
framework on Cloud Functions.
Because, if you're
just serving up
this dynamic content from the
CDN, and all of your assets
are being served from
the CDN, and you're not
making any client-side network
requests to template your data,
there tends to be, even on
a really low-power device,
I have seen really
fast load times.
And that's something that
I haven't seen in the past.
A lot of people server-side
rendered their apps.
And they used to serve it over
a CDN or something static,
but now they have to
use a dynamic server.
And it can take a second to
just generate their content.
And that's already a
second before the user
sees anything on the page.
So as far as
amazing things, I've
just seen the performance
implications out of this
is really, really cool.
And the amount of code that it
takes is just kind of amazing.
I've seen like 20
lines, 30 lines of code
to implement the whole thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So that sounds awesome.
You said that you
were doing a series.
Is that a series on YouTube?
What's the name?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
So on the Firebase
YouTube channel,
just YouTube.com/Firebase,
there's a whole series that
I'm currently running called,
"Server-side Rendering with
JavaScript Frameworks."
And the whole thing
is that we take a look
one framework at a time
how you would set this up.
And then we follow up with
a companion video that
is a performance profiling.
So we take a look
at what tools you
use to profile the
performance of your website
or your server-side
rendered website.
And we take a look
at how fast is
the non-server-side
rendered version?
How fast is the server-side
And we don't just take
a look at numbers.
I go into Tools
like web page tests,
which allows you to run real
devices around the world.
And you can simulate
really slow networks.
And then they give you basically
the Chrome DevTools view up
on the website.
And they also give you lots
of other great kind of graphs
and profiles where you can see,
how hard was the CPU working
on the device?
And when was your first paint?
And when were you fully loaded?
And so we kind of
step through each one
of those metrics
on each version,
and we see which
one came out on top.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So that YouTube
series sounds amazing.
Are there any
other places people
should go if this stuff sounds
particularly interesting?
DAVID EAST: I actually did a
Kickstarter course on this.
Or I called it a crash course.
So also on the Firebase
YouTube channel,
it's called like "Node.js Crash
Course on Firebase Hosting,"
or something like that.
And that is essentially
like, hey, I've
never done this before.
How do I get started?
And I go from blank folder
to fully-deployed website
with Cloud Functions
and Firebase Hosting.
So that's a really good spot.
And also, the
official documentation
is really good, too.
So if you're sort of
a Firebase Hosting pro
and you've used Cloud
Functions before,
it's really going to
be just like one or two
lines of configuration to get
them talking to each other.
So definitely, the
official documentation
is a really good place as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Well, we've kind
of run out of time,
but I'd like to give
you the opportunity
to plug anything else that
you'd like to tell our audience.
DAVID EAST: Yes.
We just shipped Cloud
Firestore, which
is something that we've been
working on really, really hard.
And honestly, just from my
own personal standpoint,
I'm really, really
excited about it
because now you can do a lot
more complex querying, which
is something that the real-time
database was limited on.
And for me, I'm just
mind-blown that we can finally
do completely-persisted
offline for web.
So if you're building
progressive web apps,
it's kind of amazing
that you kind of just
enable persistence in
your Cloud Firestore app,
and then that's it.
So if you have a service
worker and the user
goes offline, boom,
you are still up
and running with all of your
data from Cloud Firestore.
And then when they
go back online,
all the data gets resynced,
and conflict resolution
is automatically
handled for you.
So it's kind of amazing.
I feel like we're in this total
brand new world of development
where I can use Cloud
Firestore to store all my data,
use Cloud Functions and
Firebase Hosting to do
all my dynamic content
or my static content.
And it's kind of like the web
that we were promised back
in HTML5 days.
I can kind of start
seeing it happen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Well, that sounds
really, really cool.
And who knows, maybe
we have something
to mention also about it with
some episode or something.
But that's a secret.
Anyway, thanks so much, David,
for taking the time today.
DAVID EAST: Thank you,
so much, for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was amazing to discover
what Cloud Functions is.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Thanks so much, David.
DAVID EAST: All right.
Have a good one, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again, to David East,
for coming back to the podcast
for the second or third time.
I don't know.
I see him all the time
around the office,
so it's hard to tell.
And tell us a little bit about
Cloud Functions for Firebase
and Firebase hosting.
Lots of really cool
stuff, especially when
you want to get started easily
and just have a simple website,
just put it there.
Super simple.
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Absolutely.
Totally agreed on
the simplicity.
And the developer
experience is really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I mean, it's Firebase.
Firebase developer experience
is kind of the best.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we talk about
our question of the week.
So I can read documentation,
I can read books,
but sometimes I like to
work on a specific project,
or I like to have sort
of an instructor-led sort
of scenario.
Are there any online
courses that I
can take when trying to learn
about Google Cloud Platform?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
There's actually a lot of them.
And I'm not going to
cover all of them,
but there is a
specific set of them
that are starting this
week, which are really cool.
They're on Coursera.
They're all free.
And I recommend all of them.
And if you want to
get started, there's
some specific things, like for
instance Google Cloud Platform
Fundamentals--
Core Infrastructure.
So you're going to
be learning really
the basics of Google Cloud.
But also you have another
one in state engineering
on Google Cloud
Platform specialization,
which if you want to do
more like big data stuff,
that's for you.
There's also Architecting
with Google Cloud Platform
Specialization.
So if you want to figure out,
like I have a big application
and I want to know what
services could help me do what,
that's the one for you.
And also, if you're coming
from AWS and you want to know--
basically, I have
all of these baggage,
I know all of these
things already, just
tell me the things I need to
know on top to understand how
Google Cloud Platform works--
there's one
specifically for that,
which is Google Cloud
Platform Fundamentals for AWS
Professionals.
And last but not
least, there's also
one for people that are running
Windows applications on Google
Cloud Platform.
There's another course for that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there's a bunch of courses.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They're
all starting on October 16,
except for the Windows one,
which started on October 9.
So go check it out.
Even if you start a little
bit late, it's totally fine.
So I definitely recommend
going and registering
and learning a lot of it.
You can follow your own pace,
so perfect for those people
working that want to learn more.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, Francesc.
I think you're getting
on a plane soon.
Where are you headed?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So right
now, if I'm not mistaken,
I'm on a train.
MARK MANDEL: You're on a train?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm on a train.
Yeah, I'm on the train
going from London
to Paris because,
tomorrow, October 19,
I will be speaking at the
Google Cloud Summit Paris.
And then, after that, I'll
come back to San Francisco,
and then I'll go back
to Paris for dotGo.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So what about you?
MARK MANDEL: When this comes
out, I will be on a plane.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: While
you're on a train heading
to Melbourne, Australia, I'll
be speaking at GDG Melbourne
DevFest.
I'll be hanging out
at Unite Melbourne,
speaking at Game
Connect Asia Pacific,
and I'll be hanging out
at PAX Australia as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
So looking forward to that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Thank you so much, Mark.
And thanks so much again to
David for this awesome episode.
Thanks all for listening.
And please register,
[LAUGHS] subscribe
to where you're using this,
like Apple Podcasts or Stitcher.
MARK MANDEL: Where all
good podcasts are found.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Your local podcast distribution
system that you want to use.
And let us know what you
think about the podcast.
We want all of those
reviews to understand
better what you're looking for.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thank you
so much, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]